bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat pour la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
les seules questions d'actualité de
cette session extraordinaire ici au
sénat et avant cette séance marisol
touraine la ministre des affaires
sociales est notre invité bonjour je
vous remercie d'être avec nous en direct
votre première réaction cet après midi
au rapport de la cour des comptes et aux
déficits plus accrue que prévu de la
sécurité sociale 14 milliards d'euros
fin nous savons que le déficit de la
sécurité sociale restent importants même
si quelques progrès ont été réalisés
pour nous il s'agit évidemment d'un
enjeu majeur et je le dis l'objectif du
rétablissement des comptes de
l'équilibré en 2017 et notre objectif
mais contrairement aux gouvernements
précédents il ne s'agit pas d'y arriver
en faisant porter toute la pression sur
les épaules des patients ou des assurés
sociaux de façon plus large mais il
s'agit d'engager des réformes de fond
qui vont permettre pour
l'assurance-maladie de mieux organiser
notre système de soins et pour les
retraites d'avoir un financement dans la
durée
alors quelles sont les pistes de
réflexion du gouvernement justement pour
atteindre ces objectifs nous allons
commencer dès cette année à mettre en
place des politiques de fond avec
plusieurs axes nous l'avons dit le
premier c'est évidemment celui de la
diversification des ressources parce que
la sécurité sociale
elle a besoin d'être alimentée d'avoir
des recettes et il n'y a aucune raison
pour que ce soit uniquement des
cotisations sur le travail qui
contribuent nous voulons donc rétablir
l'équité entre la contribution des
revenus sur le capital et des revenus
sur le travail deuxième orientation
il s'agit de mieux encadrer la
consommation de médicaments on sait que
les français restent sinon les champions
du monde en tout cas
dans le x parade de ceux qui par vie
dans les pays développés prennent des
médicaments voilà un axe de réforme puis
troisième grande orientation c'est
l'amélioration du système de soins nous
savons qu'il y a dans notre pays trop de
gens qui vont aux urgences et qui
restent parfois trop longtemps il y a là
des sources importantes d'économie alors
vous parlez des médicaments à l'instant
il ya un livre qui fait beaucoup de
bruit depuis deux jours c'est celui des
professeurs debré et even la moitié des
médicaments qui sont commercialisés en
france ne servirait à rien c'est quoi
votre réaction vous aujourd'hui à ce
livre c'est un livre qui est
spectaculaire moi je voudrais dire quand
même que la plupart des médicaments ont
une utilité ils permettent de soigner
permettent de guérir pour autant il faut
être attentif
d'abord à ne pas trop en consommer on a
tendance à trop pour consommer et
ensuite à s'assurer que tous les
médicaments qui sont sur le marché sont
effectivement utile que leur service
médical comme on dit que leur utilité
médicale est concrète il ya pour cela
une agence l'agencé nationale de
sécurité du médicament qui s'assure de
l'utilité des mines utilité médicale
encore une fois des médicaments et moi
je fais confiance notamment depuis la
sphère du médiator les français doutent
c'est à dire comment les résoudre n
entendez il a faim du médiator n'a
strictement rien à voir
moi je crois que justement il faut
éviter les amalgames le médiator c'est
pas les médicaments c'est un laboratoire
qui avait décidé de contourner les
règles de mentir sur les qualités ou sur
les caractéristiques de son médicament
pour faire de l'argent donc il ne
roulait pas à rassurer
on ne peut pas mettre tous les
médicaments ou toutes les démarches dans
le même panier il y à une agence qui est
chargé de vérifier la qualité des
médicaments l'utilité médicale le niveau
de remboursement
c'est en fonction de cela qu'ils de ces
travaux qui doivent être réalisés en
pleine transparence qu'il faut avancer
le point central c'est évidemment de
s'assurer de l'indépendance des experts
et c'est ma préoccupation et ma volonté
très bien marré seul thorel merci
d'avoir été notre invité en direct de
cette salle des conférences du sénat
je voulais laisser rejoindre l'hémicycle
puisqu'on entend la sonnerie retentit et
donc la séance des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement va sans doute débuter
dans quelques instants
alors parmi les points sur lesquels le
gouvernement va être interpellé
cet après midi au sénat et bien une
question d'abord de l'ancien premier
ministre jean pierre raffarin il
interpelle l'actuel premier ministre
jean-marc ayrault sur les 100 premiers
jours du gouvernement
ayrault autre question celle du sénateur
vert ronan dantec lui il interpelle la
ministre de l'ecologie delphine batho
sur l'accident à la centrale de
fessenheim alors que demain s'ouvre la
conférence gouvernementale sur
l'environnement le sénateur communiste
éric bocquet et lui va interpeller le
gouvernement sur l'évasion fiscale et
bien sûr on imagine sur la sphère
bernard arnault qui a défrayé la
chronique tout au long du week-end
dernier
et puis vous aurez également lors de
cette séance des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement à cet après midi au
sénat une question sur psa aulnay alors
que le gouvernement par le biais du
rapport sartorius pardon à avaliser
cette semaine leur
le plan psa et la fermeture d'aulnay est
également une question du vice président
du sénat didier guillaume sur le
déplacement du président de la
république à rennes et la situation de
l'agriculture française et puis enfin
également une question du sénateur ump
louis sur les roms
voilà donc cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement va démarrer
je vous laisse rejoindre avec nous
l'hémicycle du sénat très bonne séance à
tout ça
questions d'actualité au gouvernement je
rappelle que l'auteur de la question
de même que le ou la ministre pour sa
réponse disposent chacun de deux minutes
trente
la parole est à monsieur roman dantec
pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre madame la ministre
collègues
vous avez déclaré il ya quelques jours
madame la ministre que la centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim je vous cite
serait fermé le plus tôt possible
le groupe écologiste au sénat se réjouit
bien évidemment de cette déclaration
cohérente avec les engagements du
président de la république et l'accord
politique passé entre les formations de
la majorité gouvernementale
nous attendons maintenant évidemment les
conclusions de l'enquêté que vous avez
demandé sur les circonstances de
l'incident qui a blessé la semaine
dernière à fessenheim deux agents d'edf
mais ne feront certainement que
confirmer ce que nous savons déjà que
cette centrale est la plus vétuste du
parc nucléaire français est qu'elle est
particulièrement dangereuse en raison de
ses spécificités bien connu faible
épaisseur du radier situation en zone
sismique et en contrebas d'un canal mais
aussi au vu des problèmes de
fonctionnement et de maintenance qui
font parler d'eux on se souvient de l'
incendie observé en avril dans le
réacteur numéro 2 et ce n'est qu'un
exemple on a recensé pas moins de 23
incidents depuis le redémarrage ce même
réacteur le 8 mars dernier
il est donc évident que cette centrale
fait aujourd'hui peser un risque
environnemental extrêmement lourd et
qu'elle doit donc être fermée de manière
urgente
le plus tôt possible pour reprendre les
propos de madame la ministre
cette urgence est aussi économique si
nous voulons mobiliser l'ensemble des
acteurs industriels sur la voie de la
transition énergétique
ils ne se contenteront pas de
déclarations générales pour investir il
leur faut des signaux forts
début juillet andré claude lacoste
président de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire a affirmé devant la commission
des affaires économiques de l'assemblée
nationale je cite suite à la révision
qui a été menée sur le réacteur numéro 1
de la centrale de fessenheim en sus des
examens de sûreté post fukushima
nous avons exigé l'épaississement du
béton du radier cette mesure devra être
effectif d'ici à l'été 2013 sans quoi le
réacteur ne pourra continuer à
fonctionner nous prendrons sont toutes
les mêmes prescriptions pour fessenheim
2 nous avons donc peut-être là le
calendrier de fermeture ce premier
signal fort de mobilisation des acteurs
économiques de la transition énergétique
ma question madame lycée donc fort
simple pensez vous au vu des coûts
extrêmement important des travaux de
renforcement du radier au bas mot
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
imagina d'engager des investissements
aussi important pour une centrale amené
à fermer le plus tôt possible et votre
gouvernement ayant multiplié les
déclarations selon lesquelles ils
respecteraient scrupuleusement les avis
de l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire la
scène mettant donc une date butoir à
juillet 2013
de fait et en toute déduction logique le
véritable calendrier de fermeture de
fessenheim n'était donc pas tout
simplement l'été 2013 merci pour me
répondre madame delphine batho ministre
de l'écologie du développement durable
et de l'énergie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur ronan dantec permettez moi de
vous remercier de votre question qui me
donne l'occasion d'apporter un certain
nombre de précisions sur l'incident qui
s'est produit à fessenheim le 5
septembre dernier qui est un incident
sans gravité sans enjeux de sûreté
le rapport que j'ai demandé à edf m'a
été rendue ce matin il sera rendu public
cet après midi il sera complété par le
rapport de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire et l'origine de cet incident
était donc l'adjonction sous forme
solide d'un catalyseur dans une
préparation d'eau oxygénée qui a
entraîné un dégagement de vapeur qui a
déclenché l'alarmé incendie qui a
automatiquement entraîné l'intervention
des pompiers
il n'y a pas eu de blessés
deux agents ont été ont eu des
hésitations aux mains ont été examiné
par le médecin et ont rapidement repris
le travail ce qui me permet de dire que
cet incident ne méritait pas l'ampleur
médiatique qui l'avait pris et dont il a
fait l'objet est donc cet incident est
sans rapport avec l'engagement qu'a
prise le président de la république
concernant la fermeture de la centrale
de fessenheim engagement qui sera tenue
et dont j'ai indiqué effectivement ces
derniers jours que le calendrier précis
pour pouvoir procéder à cette forme
fermeture dans des conditions
responsable responsable en termes de
sécurité d'approvisionnement électrique
responsables aussi pour la préservation
des emplois seraient discutées dans le
débat national sur la transition
énergétique c'est donc ce qui sera fait
enfin dernier point par rapport aux
recommandations et aux prescriptions de
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire vous le
savez très bien les recommandations et
les prescriptions de l'autorité de
sûreté s'impose à tous elle s'impose à
l'état
elle s'impose aux opérateurs elles
doivent donc être respecté l'autorité de
sûreté a demandé que les travaux soient
réalisés d'ici le 30 juin 2013 cela doit
donc être fait la sûreté n'est pas une
variable d'ajustement est donc ces
travaux ne faut en rien un obstacle à
l'engagement qui a été pris concernant
la fermeture de fessenheim et qui sera
tenu merci la parole est à présent
monsieur eric moquée pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen bien
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adressait à monsieur ministre de
l'économie et des finances mais elle
peut tout autant s'adressait monsieur
cahuzac ministre du budget
l'actualité récente en france a remis à
la une des journaux le sujet de
l'évasion fiscale vous le savez monsieur
le ministre une commission d' enquête du
sénat sur le sujet un rendu public son
rapport le 24 juin et juillet derniers
voter je le précise à l'unanimité il
sera présenté d'ailleurs en détail dans
cet hémicycle le 3 octobre prochain
soixante et une proposition y figurent
la première consisterait en la création
d'un haut commissariat qui serait
chargée de la protection des intérêts
financiers publics et pourrait
constituer la pierre angulaire de la
mise en place d'une politique de lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale
déterminez permanente et efficace
compte tenu des enjeux financiers estimé
entre 40 et 50 milliards d'euros
manquants chaque année au budget de
l'état est contenue aussi les
difficultés aggravées pour une grande
majorité de nos concitoyens je me fais
ici le porte parole des membres de la
commission qui à l'unanimité ont affirmé
leur volonté forte que des suites
effective soit donnée aux travaux de la
commission denquête j'entends toujours
parler de la nécessaire maîtrise des
dépenses de l'état je souhaiterais tout
autant que l'on parle de la nécessaire
maîtrise de ses recettes
une milliardaire new yorkaise déclara un
jour que les impôts étaient pour les
petites gens
je fais mienne pour ma part cette
citation de henry morgenthau ministre
des finances du président roosevelt en
1937 il disait je cite les impôts sont
le prix d'une société civilisée trop de
citoyens veulent une civilisation au
rabais fin de citation c'est donc au nom
de la commission
et en tant que rapporteur que je vous
fait remettre aujourd'hui un exemplaire
de ce rapport
de même que je le ferais pas revenir en
toute amitié à notre collègue député qui
demandait dimanche dernier la création
d'une commission d' enquête sur
l'évasion fiscale nous gagnerons ainsi
un peu de temps car comme disent les
financiers
time is money le temps c'est de l'argent
mais chacun ici avait compris j'en viens
à ma question monsieur le ministre qui
est en fait double la première cas sera
l'attitude globale du gouvernement sur
le sujet de l'évasion fiscale en france
et ailleurs dans les années qui viennent
deuxième question quelles mesures
immédiates comptez-vous prendre dès le
projet bois de finances 2013 qui viendra
en discussion ici dans quelques semaines
je vous remercie
merci monsieur jérôme cahuzac ministre
chargé du budget merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur merci de
me donner l'occasion de remercier le
sénat d'avoir utilement contribuer
à ce dossier par précisément la
rédaction et la publication de ce
rapport vous m'en fait de tenir un
exemplaire ce sera donc le deuxième
merci par avance on n'est jamais trop
prudent lorsqu'il s'agit de puisées à
bonnes sources mais j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de discuter avec certains
d'entre vous mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de ce rapport qui
effectivement est très intéressant le
sujet est d'actualité incontestablement
car au moment où l'on s'apprête à
demander un effort vigoureux au pays il
n'est évidemment pas acceptable que cet
effort soit considérée comme injuste il
ne le serait pas davantage si d'autres
estimé pouvoir s'affranchir de l'effort
que tous ou presque vont consentir la
lutte contre l'évasion et plus
généralement contre la fraude fiscale ou
la fraude sociale sont donc des luttes
qui sont évidemment d'actualité d'ores
et déjà à l'occasion de l'examen des
lois de finances rectificative des
dispositions anti abus ont été adoptées
par le parlement
et bien évidemment par votre assemblée
vous en avez probablement le souvenir
d'autres dispositions seront proposés au
parlement dans le cadre
vraisemblablement d'une loi de finances
rectificative qui renforceront les
moyens de l'administration dans ses
pouvoirs d'investigation d' enquête et
surtout de recouvrement car actuellement
si la lutte contre les erreurs ou la
fraude permet à l'état de récupérer un
peu plus de 16 milliards d'euros chaque
année la fraude elle-même ouvre droit à
quatre milliards d'euros de notification
dont seulement la moitié
monsieur le sénateur et recouvrait ce
pourcentage ne traduit pas une
efficacité satisfaisante aux yeux du
gouvernement et c'est la raison pour
laquelle des moyens supplémentaires
seront données à l'administration
compétente afin que cette efficacité
s'améliore je crois que chacun ne pourra
que s'en féliciter voilà quelques
éléments que je pourrai donc porter à
votre connaissance si j'ai bien
conscience de pouvoir compter sur
l'ensemble de la haute assemblée pour à
l'occasion des textes législatifs
compléter les dispositifs dont nous
disposons déjà dispositif qu'ils ont
déjà été utilement me permets de le
rappeler par la création de la police
fiscale c'était sous la précédente
mandature ce fut une heureuse initiative
d'ailleurs adopté de manière
consensuelle
reste maintenant peut-être à l'utiliser
à sa juste mesure
la parole est à présent monsieur
stéphane mazars pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique social
européen
merci monsieur le président le premier
ministre madame messieurs les ministres
mes chers confrères
donc cette question s'adresse à madame
louise l'artisanat du commerce et du
tourisme madame le ministre lundi à
l'issue d'une réunion avec les
professionnels du secteur vous avez
assuré que le projet de loi de finances
pour 2013 ne contiendra pas de
relèvement du taux de la tva dans la
restauration
après avoir été abaissée à 5,5 en 2009
ce taux a été relevé à 7 % au 1er
janvier dernier
faut-il remonter davantage faut-il fixer
un nouveau taux intermédiaire à 12% par
exemple ou faut-il revenir à 19,6 avant
de répondre à ces interrogations
vous avez indiqué que la position du
gouvernement était d'ouvrir une
concertation prévue pour durer jusqu'à
la fin octobre de cette année et ce afin
d'établir un bilan contradictoire et
transparent des véritables effets de
cette mesure effets sur les prix effets
sur l'emploi effets sur les conditions
de travail et enfin un effet sur la
modernisation du secteur
madame la ministre votre méthode est
pertinente
il est en effet grand temps d'établir un
véritable bilan chiffré de cette baisse
de la tva décidée en lattes et dans les
conditions que l'on sait car jusqu'ici
elle n'a fait l'objet d'aucune réelle
évaluation
si bien que la controverse demeure et
reviennent périodiquement à chaque
discussion budgétaire
la seule donnée dont on dispose c'est
son coup pour nos finances publiques de
l'ordre de 3 milliards d'euros
face à la situation économique et
budgétaire que nous connaissons est
alors que des efforts très importants
vont être demandés aux français pour
participer au redressement du pays
il n'est pas envisageable de maintenir
ce taux réduit si et je dis bien si son
efficacité économique n'est pas
démontrée autrement dit s'il s'avère que
les professionnels du secteur ne jouent
pas le jeu à respecter leurs engagements
c'est une question d'équité nous
attendons donc maintenant les résultats
de cette concertation et de cette
évaluation avant que des décisions ne
soient prises par le gouvernement et le
parlement
madame la ministre pouvez vous nous en
dire davantage sur les intentions
actuelles du gouvernement
han feng envisagez-vous d'associer la
représentation nationale
à cette concertation très bien merci
alors pour la réponse au madame sylvia
pinel ministre de l'artisanat du
commerce et du tourisme
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur stéphane mazars je vous
remercie de me donner l'occasion de
d'éclairer la représentation nationale
sur ce dossier complexe de la tva
restauration
ce secteur est un secteur essentiel pour
notre économie
plus de deux cent mille entreprises 5%
du pib et environ 15000 e création
pérenne quinze mille créations d'emplois
par an c'est donc un secteur essentiel
le contrat d'avenir conclu entre l'état
et les organisations professionnelles en
2009 complété par un avenant en 2011
avait demandé aux restaurateurs certain
nombre de contreparties pour légitimer
justifier cet abaissement du taux de tva
au regard du coût de cette mesure plus
de 3 2 milliards d'euros par an il est
bien entendu légitime que le
gouvernement se pose la question de son
efficacité et de la pertinence de cette
mesure
c'est dans cet état d'esprit est alors
que ce bilan n'a jamais été voulue par
le gouvernement précédent que lundi
dernier j'ai réuni à bercy les
organisations professionnelles pour leur
présenter la méthode de travail et le
calendrier
ce bilan sera établi de manière
contradictoire en associant les
professionnels de la restauration dans
quatre groupes de travail qui représente
les objectifs principaux du contrat
d'avenir
vous les avez évoqué très justement il
s'agit de l'emploi des de la baisse des
prix de la modernisation du secteur est
également d
des conditions de travail qui était très
attendue par les salariés qui sont très
importants dans ce dans le domaine de la
restauration
donc nous allons travailler à partir
dans 15 jours nous allons nous réunir
pour faire le point très précis et
confronter les chiffres puisque vous
avez entendu et vu comme moi que les
professionnels annoncé un certain nombre
de résultats les chiffres de mes
services sont différents donc nous
devons faire le point de manière plus
exhaustif mais ce bilan ne doit pas se
contenter d'être une querelle de
chiffres il faut aussi regarder quels
sont les disparités géographiques qui
peuvent exister
la taille des entreprises celles qui ont
fait des efforts sont elles les plus
petits tout au contraire les grandes
chaînes de restauration et les
différences qui peuvent exister entre la
restauration traditionnelle et la
restauration rapide
vous le voyez monsieur le sénateur le
gouvernement un principe la justice un
objectif le redressement économique du
pays
dans la volonté de travailler avec les
organisations professionnelles et sur ce
cet aspect comme sur les autres le temps
de l'impréparation et de l'improvisation
des mesures est bel et bien terminée
merci je passe à présent la parole à
monsieur le premier ministre jean pierre
raffarin pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire que le président mes
chers collègues mesdames et messieurs
les membres du gouvernement monsieur le
premier ministre ma question s'adresse à
vous voilà un peu plus de 100 jours que
notre pays a choisi l'alternance
voilà cent jours au cours desquels vous
avez engagé certaines promesses de
monsieur le président de la république
voulait remettre en cause l'action du
gouvernement précédent vous l'avez fait
vous vouliez supprimer l'avantagé fiscal
des heures supplémentaires c'est fait
vous vouliez augmenter la fiscalité
c'est fait et semble-t-il cela va
continuer nous ne vous reprocheront pas
de tenir les promesses sur lesquels vous
avez été ndash mais nous mesurons que
vos premières décisions ne répondent pas
semble-t-il aux attentes des français
et des français surtout monsieur le
premier ministre il nous semble que
l'action que vous engagez sous-estiment
quelque peu l'ampleur
la profondeur de la crise l'inquiétude
est immense dans le pays
tout le monde a compris maintenant qu'il
ne suffisait pas de changer du
gouvernement pour chasser la crise la
crise gronde
elle est toujours là elle est de plus en
plus fort la barre des 3 millions de
chômeurs a été franchi les plans sociaux
se multiplient et finalement le
gouvernement valide la fermeture
d'aulnay
monsieur le président de la république
dimanche soir nous a dit sa volonté
d'engager la bataille contre le chômage
c'est urgent
les perspectives de croissance sont
minces les entreprises les pme manquent
et vous le savez de financement et sont
étouffés par de multiples contraintes
dans mon seul département la vienne avec
mon collègue alain fouché nous
travaillons avec les entreprises des
collectivités territoriales avec
l'ensemble des partenaires la création
d'un centre parcours créé plus de 1000
emplois il va nous falloir plus de cinq
ans
si nous réussissons à surmonter tous les
obstacles pour réussir à créer ce que
l'opinion attend les créateurs d'emplois
les créateurs d'emplois sont nombreux à
éviter aux mes chers collègues il ne
s'agit pas de polémique et l'emploi
mérite autre chose que des attitudes de
polémique
les créateurs d'emplois sont nombreux
aujourd'hui à hésiter entre l'inquiétude
la colère et pour certains le
découragement
monsieur le premier ministre nous savons
que personne n'a intérêt dans le pays
à l'échec de la france ma question est
relative à notre surprise de ne pas
avoir entendu dimanche soir le président
de la république parler d'europe
alors merci de bien vouloir nous dire
après la décision allemande de karlsruhe
quelle est la part européenne de votre
combat pour l'emploi
merci monsieur jean marc ayrault premier
ministre merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre jean pierre
raffarin je vous remercie de votre
question vous avez décrit une situation
qui est celle de la france mais pas
seulement celle de la france qui est
celle aussi de la zone euro dans un
contexte mondial de croissance dégradé
tous les pays se préoccupe de cette
situation et je suis d'accord avec vous
sur un point essentiel ce que toutes les
forces doivent s'unir pour réussir le
redressement du pays mais aussi puisque
vous venez de l'évoquer la réorientation
de l'europe ça ne se décrète pas la
réorientation de l'europe le président
d'art et pluie dit vous n'en a pas parlé
mais quel a été son premier acte le jour
même de ma nomination
le jour il prenait ses fonctions le 15
mai son premier déplacement était à
berlin pour discuter avec madame merkel
de l'avenir de l'europe et vous avez vu
que il n'a pas ménagé sa peine
les premières semaines les premiers mois
de son action et déjà des résultats ont
pu être obtenus sont ils suffisants à
l'évidence non mais il faut mesurer le
chemin parcouru mais avant de développer
ce point monsieur le premier ministre
raffarin je voudrais quand même vous
dire que nous avons trouvé une situation
dégradée au delà même de ce que nous
imaginions parce que nous étions
conscients
je les dis dans ma déclaration de
politique générale le 3 juillet dernier
de la gravité de la crise le président
de la république l'a rappelé à chalon
ans enfin champagne il a parlé de crise
exceptionnelle de gravité exceptionnelle
oui cette situation nous l'avons trouvée
vous avez parlé de psa mais nous avons
trouvé aussi des plans sociaux retarder
des secteurs industriels en grande
difficulté des difficultés d'accès au
crédit
non seulement pour les les pubs les pme
et les tpe mais aussi y compris les
collectivités territoriales
c'est la réalité
face à laquelle nous sommes et sur
laquelle nous agissons chaque jour avec
détermination tout en faisant face à
l'urgence et je vous remercie d'ailleurs
d'avoir annoncé que même si vous ne
partagez pas nos choix politiques que
vous êtes l'un de ceux qui alliez voter
les ans le projet le projet du
gouvernement les emplois d'avenir
oui parce que dans l'urgence on ne peut
pas laisser tomber ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui si éloignées de l'emploi je
pense à ces jeunes sans qualification
donc il faut relever à la fois le défi
de la réforme de notre système éducatif
de la fondation de l'école qui
nécessitera des moyens mais aussi du
temps pour former à nouveau les
professeurs les mettre là où nous en
avons besoin
mais en même temps il faut agir dans
l'urgence c'est le sens des contrats de
génération qui compléteront le premier
dispositif que je viens d'évoquer comme
les mesures concernant le pouvoir
d'achat puisque vous aurez aussi un
autre texte à voter
concernant la tarification progressive
du gaz et de l'électricité qui vient
s'ajouter au programme que vous avez
voté hier que madame duflot a présenté
le plan pour le logement est ce que ça
va suffire pour réorienter et notre
économie dans le sens de la croissance
évidence non les réformes de structure
je les ai vus évoqué nous les engageons
j'en ai évoqué une qui est essentielle
mais hier avec le président de la
république nous avons réuni les
présidents des régions et c'est un sujet
auquel je sais que vous êtes sensibles
nous avons signé avec le président
rousset j'ai signé un accord sur 15
engagements qu un engagement réciproque
des conseils régionaux qui connaissent
la réalité du territoire qui connaissent
la réalité de nos entreprises de nos pme
de nos tpe qui connaissent la réalité
des deux pays
ces entreprises de taille intermédiaire
encore pas assez nombreuses et pas assez
puissante et bien ce que nous avons
décidé de faire qui vous sera présenté
dans quelques semaines c'est la mise en
place de la banque publique
d'investissement vous avez parlé de
crédit d'accès au crédit et bien le
président de la république dans son
discours du bourget avait dit que la
finance devait être mise au service de
l'économie est bien le premier acte qui
ira dans ce sens
c'est la banque publique
d'investissement qui sera gérée à la
fois à l'échelle nationale mais qui aura
aussi des antennes régionales dans
lesquelles les conseils régionaux seront
impliqués y compris dans les procédures
d'engagement parce que nous voulons
aider les pme à la fois pour
l'innovation à la fois pour leur
investissement à la fois pour
l'exportation donc c'est le défi que
nous relevons j'ai même fixé un objectif
concernant le commerce extérieur que
aujourd'hui nous sommes à 25 milliards
de déficit hors énergie et qu'à la fin
du quinquennat
nous arrivions au moins à l'équilibré
bien ça c'est un engagement extrêmement
volontariste comme l'engagement du
président de la république de lutter
contre le chômage
mais c'est vrai que au delà d'un
nécessaire maîtrise de nos comptes
publics qui sont très dégradés que nous
avons commencé à traiter des la loi de
finances 2012 la rectificative 2012 qui
sera aussi l'objet de la loi de finances
2013 l'objectif des 3%
ce n'est pas l'extérieur qui nous
l'imposent c'est notre décision de
maîtriser notre dette de maîtriser cette
dette qui a augmenté de 600 milliards en
un an
parce que c'est notre indépendance notre
souveraineté qui est en jeu et 100 107
actions
nous ne retrouverons pas les marges de
manoeuvre nécessaires à condition bien
sûr que cette loi de finances soit juste
et elle le sera à l'image des décisions
que nous avons déjà prises depuis le
mois de mai dernier par décret ou par
les votes du parlement mais c'est
nécessaire parce que nous ne voulons pas
nous laisser imposer par les marchés
financiers
un plan d'austérité qui perdent qui
mettrait à mal l'avenir de notre pays
nous voulons garder notre liberté
reconquérir des marges de manoeuvre pour
que au lieu de dépenser d'abord l'argent
public dans le remboursement de la dette
ne le mettions dans les investissements
de la vda venir parce que notre pays en
a besoin
chez le choix que nous avons fait et
quant à l'europe et bien l'élection de
françois hollande a permis de faire
bouger les lignes
à l'évidence sens-là sens le vote des
français
il aurait été bien difficile d'obtenir
le pacte de croissance au conseil des 28
et 29 juin dernier il aurait été bien
difficile de lancer le chantier
concernant la supervision des banques
sous l'autorité de la banque centrale
européenne ou de l'union bancaire
indispensable
il aurait été sans doute très difficile
est sans doute impossible d'obtenir la
taxe sur les transactions financières
que nous réclamons depuis tant d'années
et qui n'était pas possible de faire à
l'échelle de l'europe
ces résultats c'est grâce aux votes des
français que nous les avons obtenus mais
nous souhaitons aller plus loin après la
ratification qui j'espère sera adoptée
par le parlement
avec la loi organique mais aussi les
perspectives sur l'avenir de la
construction européenne il faudra qu'il
y ait aussi un débat entre dirigeants
européens pour qu'il y ait à la fois
conciliation entre la nécessaire
maîtrise des comptes publics
la dette la lutte contre la dette et les
déficits mais aussi des initiatives de
croissance le conseil européen des 28 et
9 9 juin a permis une avancée mais elle
n'est pas suffisante
et vous savez que c'est attendu par non
pas seulement par la france mais que nos
partenaires je pense à l'italie je pense
à l'espagne avec lesquels nous discutons
souvent le souhaite aussi
alors sur ce plan-là je crois que nous
attendons aussi le soutien du parlement
nous verrons ce que vous direz monsieur
le premier ministre raffarin
mais la nécessaire réorientation de
l'europe dans le sens de la croissance
c'est la responsabilité pas de la france
seule mais nous y mettrons toutes nos
énergies toute notre énergie toute notre
part mais c'est la responsabilité
historique des dirigeants européens
parce qu'il en a il en va même de
l'avenir du projet européen lui même
merci merci monsieur vincent
capo-canellas ce pour le groupe de
l'union centriste et républicaine
monsieur le président monsieur le préfet
ministre à mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre du redressement
productif
avant d'être élu monsieur le président
de la république avait déclaré aux
salariés de psa aulnay sous bois après
le 6 mai si les français me choisisse
nous auront rendez vous le rendez vous
n'a pas tardé les effets de la crise que
connaît le secteur automobile aggravée
par les difficultés spécifiques à une
entreprise qui a choisi et c'est heureux
de concentrer sa production en france
ont conduit à la naissance d'un plan
social de grande ampleur
certes psa s'est engagé à ne procéder à
aucun licenciement sec
mais ce plan est un traumatisme fort
pour les salariés l'entreprise nous en
mesurons les conséquences pour eux comme
pour le territoire qui accueille le site
d'aulnay et bien évidemment le
département de la seine saint denis la
fermeture du site d'aulnay est un sujet
d'ampleur nationale à la suite de
négociations et de compromis négocié
entre les salariés et l'entreprise
au contraire le site de sevelnord sera
pérennisée ma collègue valérie l'état a
suivi de près ce sujet ce contre exemple
doit nous fournir une base de discussion
pour l'ensemble des sujets industriels
la négociation plutôt que l'outrance le
dialogue plutôt que la mise en cause
l'adaptation négociées plutôt que les
rodomontades sans suite
monsieur le ministre on ne peut pas
jouer avec le désespoir des salariés et
d'un territoire qui souffre en juillet
monsieur prison d'un public considéré ce
plan inacceptable en l'état
dimanche soir sur tf1 le chef de l'état
a finalement appelé à trouver des
compromis pour qu'il y ait moins
d'emplois supprimés et plus de
reconversion vous appeler maintenant
chez ministre à des réunions tripartites
n'auriez-vous pas dû dès le départ
appelé ainsi au dialogue renégocier
reformater réduire le plan social vite
vous oui sans doute mais dès lors que
votre propre experts l'estiment légitime
est quasi inévitable
n'est ce pas vous compliquer la tâche
monsieur le ministre on peine sur un
sujet aussi douloureux avoir votre
stratégie
et comme il s'agit dialogue social j'ai
écouté avec attention les appréciations
des syndicats monsieur montebourg nous a
dit avant l'été je vais tout empêcher
c'est inadmissible il a donné de
l'espoir au salary peugeot et
aujourd'hui nous dit calmez vous soyez
raisonnable au lieu de se prendre pour
un super syndicaliste le rôle du
ministre était plutôt de regarder la
réalité en face et les difficultés
telles qu'elles existent ces phrases qui
peuvent paraître provocante ne sont pas
de moi elles sont du secrétaire général
de la cfdt françois chérèque
monsieur ministre qu'elle est enfin
votre politique la politique du
gouvernement pour psa aulnay qu en
parlerez vous
aux salariés avec lucidité quand
parlerez-vous dialogue social
compétitivité revitalisation du
territoire maintient l'emploi et
accompagnement exigent des reconversions
merci monsieur arnaud montebourg
ministre du redressement productif
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur capo-canellas vous m'interrogez
sur les conditions dans lesquelles le
gouvernement fait face un plan social
massif qui a choqué les français
traumatisé les salariés de psa lesquels
s'inquiètent de l'avenir de cette
entreprise
le gouvernement a d'abord choisi de
faire la lumière c'est à dire de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé pour que
psa en soit arrivé là
il a chargé et en a informé les
organisations syndicales les élus
territoriaux des régions concernées
monsieur emmanuel sartorius ingénieur
général des mines qui a fait un travail
très appuyé avec son équipe plural où il
a examiné la situation
le rapport est assez clair il dit
d'abord que il y a des difficultés
sérieuses à psa je rappelle que les
partenaires sociaux n'était pas d'accord
sur ce diagnostic avant l'été c'est un
point important important que nous
puissions partager le diagnostic pour
éviter de se tromper et particulièrement
que le gouvernement prenne le bon
positionnement dans un plan social très
douloureux où nous avons en charge bien
sûr non seulement d'aider les salariés
qui risquent de perdre leur emploi mais
aussi de ceux qui restent dans
l'entreprise et qui doivent pouvoir
compter sur un rebond une relance et une
reconquête de psa deuxièmement ce
rapport et mais un certain nombre de
jugement très sévère sur la direction au
mois de juillet je les ai montré
désigner le rapport les a confirmés et
je vous invite à le lire vous
découvrirez en effet qu'il ya eu des
erreurs de direction qui conduisent
aujourd'hui psa à se retrouver dans
cette situation
le brian n'est pas le passé il est
d'affronter ensemble l'avenir qu'est ce
que le gouvernement a dit en juillet
qu'il souhaitait que ce plan soit
renégocié reformater le disque
et que dit il aujourd'hui que ce plan
soit renégocié reformater rediscuter
nous n'avons pas changé ni de langage ni
l'exigence
la seule différence c'est que nous
savons maintenant qu'il ya des
difficultés sérieuses qui touche psa et
que dans cet exercice de reformatage qui
doit être partagé par tous nous avons
besoin partenaires sociaux donc la
direction de peugeot
les salariés les syndicats les élus
territoriaux et le gouvernement de
trouver les moyens de limiter dans la
stricte nécessité de la survie de
peugeot et des besoins de peugeot
réduire ce plan social c'est ce que le
président de la république a dit c'est
ce que j'ai déclaré devant l'ensemble
des partenaires sociaux
c'est ce que je m'apprête à dire cet
après midi devant monsieur varin le
président du groupe psa enfin il va
falloir que nous y voyons clair sur la
stratégie de rebond de psa des questions
sont dans le rapport
l'alliance avec general motors est elle
pertinente le un certain nombre
d'investissements en recherche
développement qui ne sont pas au rendez
vous là aussi ce sont des questions qui
nous préoccupent
et ce sont des éléments qui font partie
de la discussion avec la direction
donc nous allons en reparler la bataille
de la négociation commence et il est
nécessaire que la nation se rassemblent
autour du sauvetage de peugeot les
partenaires sociaux la direction de
peugeot
les élus territoriaux et bien sûr le
gouvernement de la france
merci la parole à monsieur didier
guillaume pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur stéphane le foll milices de
l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et de
la forêt monsieur le ministre le monde
agricole et rural souffre en disant ces
dix dernières années la france a perdu
le quart de ces exploitations agricoles
les revenus des agriculteurs sont trop
bas il faut tout faire pour enrayer
cette hémorragie les agriculteurs nous
font vivre
ils nourrissent nos concitoyens et sont
des acteurs indispensables de
l'aménagement du territoire nous devons
ici affirmé dans cette haute assemblée
ensemble que ces hommes et ces femmes
sont indispensables à la france
la hausse inquiétante des prix mondiaux
des céréales nous fait craindre de
revivre monsieur le ministre
le scénario de 2007 2008 avec une
flambée généralisée des matières
premières du fait de la sécheresse aux
états unis et des mauvaises mauvaises
récoltes en russie et en ukraine en
aujourd'hui une hausse très importante
des cours du maïs du soja ou du blé avec
des conséquences pour
l'approvisionnement de notre pays en
renchérissant le coût de l'alimentation
pour les animaux et les coûts de
production de la viande et du lait cette
situation met en difficulté la sent
l'ensemble des filières les revenus des
éleveurs déjà très faibles sont
susceptibles d'être encore diminué
le secteur de l'élevage est la
principale victime de cette situation
alors que c'est une activité qui
représente beaucoup d'emplois directs
mais aussi beaucoup d'emplois indirects
dans l'agroalimentaire la bataille pour
l'emploi dont le gouvernement a fait une
priorité doit aussi passer par
l'agriculture et par l'agroalimentaire
encore une fois se pose la question de
l'avenir de l'élevage dans notre pays du
fait de notre grande indépendance aux
exportations et importations d'aliments
pour animaux
encore une fois se pose la question d'un
rééquilibrage des aides agricoles dans
le cadre de la réforme de la pac pour
plus de justice entre les filières
encore une fois se pose la question
d'une régulation des marchés agricoles
mondiaux qui demeure une des solutions
pour l'agriculture et je ne parle pas du
loup qui attaquent certains troupeaux et
laisse nos éleveurs dans la détresse
il est temps de choisir entre le
pastoralisme est le prédateur
la cohabitation ces territoires est
impossible mardi le président de la
république a réaffirmé son attachement
au monde agricole
il a affiché sa volonté de faire de
l'agriculture un secteur d'avenir moteur
de la croissance
ce discours a été salué par la
profession agricole
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous en
dire un peu plus sur le plan d'action
gouvernemental face à la hausse des prix
des céréales par ailleurs où en sont les
négociations européennes sur la réforme
de la pac
je vous remercie merci monsieur stéphane
le foll
ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire de la forêt le
président monsieur des sénateurs et
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur vous
avez évoqué plusieurs sujets qui
regroupe la grande question de
l'agriculture
nous partageons un objectif c'est que
l'agriculture l'agroalimentaire c'est un
secteur majeur pour notre pays et il
faut donc en préserver les atouts en
développer les potentialités et ouvrir
des perspectives
vous avez dit qu'il y avait une
situation effectivement posées par une
flambée des prix des céréales qui fait
que l'on est dans une situation assez
paradoxale d'ailleurs puisque la flambée
des prix initial fait qu' un certain
nombre d'agriculteurs à d'exploitation
aujourd'hui bénéficient de ce haut
niveau de prix mais que ça a des
conséquences et c'est là quel paradoxe
sur d'autres exploitations qui elle au
travers de l'alimentation et bien voit
le coût de production de leur
alimentation ont augmenté
c'est la question élevage c'est pourquoi
il faut traiter cette question de cette
manière à la fois à prendre en compte la
situation et ses conséquences et
apporter des réponses à la fois sur le
court terme et sur le moyen terme
sur le moyen terme et les grandes
questions posées par la volatilité des
prix il faut une action à l'échelle
mondiale il ya eu des outils qui ont été
négociées dans le cadre du g20 que nous
avons activé pour la première fois
coordonner nos politiques à l'échelle du
monde c'est essentiel éviter que
certaines peines des positions qui soit
contraire à l'objectif c'est à dire
éviter que les prix continuent de
flamber
on a eu des réunions au niveau du g20
nous allons poursuivre il y aura une
rencontre la semaine prochaine avec le
directeur général de la fao
je me rendrai à rome pour le conseil de
sécurité alimentaire et nous allons
poursuivre pour réunir ce fameux forum
de réaction rapide ça c'est premier
temps l'échelle mondiale deuxième
question l'europe l'europe ce sujet a du
retard en particulier sur la question de
la spéculation financière qui lie à
s'ajouter aux déficits sur le marché de
l'offre par rapport à la demande et
qu'ils amplifient donc les phénomènes de
volatilité des prix c'est pourquoi le
gouverneur
a décidé de soutenir les propositions
qui vont être faites pour lutter sur les
positions spéculatives sur la base
d'ailleurs latex qui était déposée par
le commissaire européen à monsieur
barnier et sur lequel nous allons agir
pour faire en sorte que l'europe soit à
la hauteur des enjeux est évident que la
spéculation viennent s'ajouter dans ses
effets sur les évolutions des prix
agricoles
troisième point le niveau national et là
l'enjeu il est d'assurer ce que je
disais au départ une solidarité entre
des céréales et l'élevage c'est la
contribution volontaire qui a été décidé
que nous avons incité et que nous devons
saluer mais c'est aussi les moyens que
nous devons engager pour permettre les
éleveurs de passer ces phases difficiles
qu'ils connaissent aujourd'hui avec un
accord avec les banques pour pouvoir
venir directement et individuellement
face aux situations difficiles que
peuvent rencontrer les éleveurs de la
manière que comme ces demandes et la msa
aura aussi à reporter une partie des
cotisations qui doivent être versés mais
si je dis ça j'y ajoute aussi parce que
c'est important la nécessité qu en
france sur les questions agricoles et
agroalimentaires les conditions de
contractualisation c'est à dire de
négociations entre les différents
échelons des filières production
transformation distribution soient
réunies et c'est pourquoi je réunirai
dans les semaines qui viennent avec
guillaume garot une conférence sur la
question des nouveaux modèles de
contractualisation qui régnera
transformateurs producteurs et grands
distributeurs
voilà monsieur le sénateur garder
l'objectif défendre l'agriculture et
l'élevage et offrir des perspectives
c'est l'enjeu merci la parole est à
monsieur louis pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre je souhaite vous
interroger aujourd'hui sur le problème
que posent les roms sur notre territoire
c'est une question de misère humaine
c'est incontestable mais c'est aussi et
surtout un problème de réseau mafieux de
respect de l'ordre public est très
prosaïquement de respect des riverains
qui jouxte les camps de roms ou des
habitants de notre pays qui sont
victimes d'une délinquance importée qui
à terre gravement notre activité
publique de nos concitoyens en donnant
l'ordre de démanteler ces cas en sauvage
et illégaux qui sont à proprement parler
des zones de non droit vous n'avez fait
que votre devoir monsieur le ministre
vous avez même réussi à faire démanteler
un campement de roms avant toute
décision de justice mais le monde
demandions pas tant mais au delà du
démantèlement de ses installations
sauvages qui est une opération
nécessaire et légitime dans un état de
droit
mais par définition ponctuelles le
problème de fond de l'afflux de ces
migrants économiques en temps de crise
se pose
d'où ma triple question premièrement sur
la base d'une action menée à evry est-ce
que tout maire peut demander y compris
en l'absence de décisions judiciaires le
démantèlement d'un campement de roms et
plus largement quelles politiques
entendez-vous menée à l'égard du demi
millier de campements illégaux recensés
en france
deuxième question vous avez désormais
ouvert la possibilité à ces populations
d'obtenir un emploi mais n'est-ce pas
une politique inconséquente et
incohérentes
alors qu'au même moment trois millions
de personnes sont en recherche d'emploi
et que parallèlement il nous manque que
des centaines de milliers de logements
pour loger déjà ceux qui habitent
régulièrement sur notre territoire n'est
ce pas aggraver
la situation des uns et des autres enfin
l'arrivée de sérum coïncide avec une
importante augmentation de la
délinquance juvénile qui portent
gravement atteinte à la tranquillité
publique et à la sécurité à laquelle
aspirent tous nos concitoyens
l'explosion du nombre d'infractions cet
été dans ma région risquent d'entraîner
monsieur le ministre un sentiment
d'exclusion à l'égard des populations
d'origine immigrée et bien au delà des
roms d'autant plus monsieur le ministre
que la justice des mineurs est
inopérante
en ce sens en conséquence ma troisième
question est de savoir quelles mesures
concrètes
monsieur le président à assouline tout à
l'heure l'un d'entre vous a dépassé de
30 secondes
vous n'avez pas fait la remarque il ya
deux ya un président il ya un président
il n'y a pas de coin de mon cher
collègue terminé s'il vous plaît merci
monsieur le président
en conséquence la troisième question est
de savoir quelles mesures concrètes
compte prendre le gouvernement pour
juguler
monsieur le ministre efficacement cette
délinquance juvénile destructrice de la
paix sociale tim monsieur manuel valls
ministre l'intérieur
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jean louis
nous revenons avec bernard cazeneuve de
roumanie à l'instant je vais vous dire
d'abord que la rencontre avec les
autorités roumaines a été positive et
constructive au fond un nouveau climat a
été créée je veux saluer parce que c'est
à ce niveau là que les problèmes se
règlent l'engagement des autorités
roumaines qui nous assurent que leur
pays ne se dérobera pas de leurs
responsabilités et il s'agit donc de
mettre en action là aussi des projets
concrets hier nous avons signé un accord
cadre à travers l'office le financement
d'un certain nombre de projets qui
permettra d'aider à la réinsertion en
roumanie des familles rapatriées l'état
français assument aussi ses
responsabilités et la ligne du
gouvernement sous l'autorité de jean
marc ayrault est clair d'abord action au
niveau européen et ce sujet est inscrit
au prochain conseil affaires générales
et ensuite nous avons un dialogue
constructif avec la commission fermeté
les évacuations de campements illicites
se poursuivront que ce soit en
appréciations des décisions de justice
ou pour mettre fin à des situations de
danger ou de risque sanitaire
la france ne peut accepter l'existence
de bidonvilles et maintenir cette
population dans des conditions de vie
indignes et souvent à la merci des
réseaux mafieux ne constituent en aucun
cas une solution
troisièmement respect de la dignité des
personnes la concertation avec les
acteurs locaux et la mise en place de
dispositifs d'accompagnement doivent
être recherchées je vous renvoie à la
circulaire ministérielle du 26 août
dernier signé par sept ministres qui
permet d'envisager les actions de
réinsertion par le logement par l'école
et par l'emploi et la france respecte le
cadre européen et monsieur le sénateur
qu'on vous nous dites que nous ouvrons
l'emploi c'est ce que la france de toute
façon été amenés à faire et vous ne
pouvez pas opposer la parole et
l'engagement de la france dans l'europe
comme vous l'avez fait tout à l'heure
avec le premier ministre raffarin est
aujourd'hui mettre en cause cette europe
il ya là quelque chose qui me paraît
très contradictoires dans votre propos
enfin
nous allons travailler sur la question
de l'aide au retour moment où nous
revenons de roumanie je veux vous dire
qu'à la demande du premier ministre nous
allons étudier cette aide au retour
financière qui est incontestablement
pose un certain nombre d'effets pervers
mais nous le ferons
tranquillement car je veux vous rappeler
aussi monsieur le sénateur que sur bien
des sujets et celui ci n'y échappe pas
nous avons trouvé une solution qui n'a
été en aucun cas régler
malgré le funeste discours de grenoble
de 2010 et malgré tout une série de
proclamations et nous l'avons vu en
roumanie qui n'ont jamais trouvé des
faits enfin le seul sénateur
oui il faut lutter contre la délinquance
contre ces réseaux mafieux et familiaux
et nous avons renouvelé la coopération
avec le gouvernement roumain
hier encore avec le préfet de police de
paris mais aussi en étendant cette
coopération à d'autres villes avec la
police roumaine et avec des équipes
communes de policiers et d'enquêteurs
parce que là c'est essentiel que nous
luttions contre l'exploitation de la
misère humaine des jeunes pourront pas
admettre cette exploitation des mineurs
ou des femmes dans notre pays et vous
pouvez compter sur notre fermeté là
aussi la ligne du gouvernement est
claire pas de stigmatisation pas
d'utilisation de ce sujet à des fins de
populisme et des réponses concrètes
ferme qui font honneur aux valeurs de la
france
merci madame michelle meunier pour le
groupe socialiste et apparentés
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
la madame la ministre des droits des
femmes porte parole du gouvernement
il y a dix ans dans la nuit du 13 au 14
septembre 2002 françois chenu mourrait
assassiné au seul motif qu'il était
homosexuel
dix ans après ce crime odieux le premier
ministre vous confie madame la ministre
une mission de lutte contre l'homophobie
nous ne pouvons que nous en féliciter
tant cette question est importante
s'il nous faut avancer concrètement vers
l'égalité de toutes et tous dans notre
pays et le droit au mariage et à
l'adoption est un premier pas notre
détermination doit aussi contribuer à
favoriser le droit à la différence
partout où des personnes sont condamnées
pour aimer quelqu'un
or sexe faut-il le rappeler les
personnes homosexuelles ou transsexuels
sont particulièrement exposés aux
violences sous toutes leurs formes
l'homophobie et la transphobie la
lesbophobie compte d'ailleurs parmi les
premières causes de suicide chez les
jeunes
il nous faut donc agir des textes
existent au niveau national et européen
il manque toutefois une action
transversale et coordonnée et c'est tout
le sens de la mission que le premier
ministre vient de vous confier en
matière de discrimination ce sont
toujours les mêmes mécanismes de
domination de rejet et de mépris de
l'autre qui agissent et je ne doute pas
de votre volonté à agir sur ces sujets
qui relèvent de votre ministère la
résolution du conseil de l'europe
relative à la discrimination sur la base
de l'orientation sexuelle ou de
l'identité de genre précise que le
manque de connaissance et de
compréhension du sujet est un défi que
doivent relever les états et que je cite
l'éradication de l'homophobie et de la
transphobie nécessite une volonté
politique pour mettre en oeuvre une
approche cohérente en matière des droits
de l'homme et de se lancer dans un vaste
éventail d'initiatives
c'est pourquoi je vous demande madame la
ministre de bien vouloir nous indiquer
comment vous comptez agir pour lutter
efficacement contre ces discriminations
liées à l'orientation sexuelle et au
genre je remercie
merci madame najat vallaud-belkacem
ministre des droits de femmes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice meunier d'abord merci à vous
d'avoir rappelé la mémoire de françois
chenu sauvagement assassinée il y a dix
ans à reims
je crois que ce crime odieux marque
encore nos esprits et j'ai une pensée
aujourd'hui pour sa famille oui vous
l'avez dit au delà des belles avancées
que nous nous apprêtons à adopter et qui
vous seront présentés ici même par mes
collègues taubira et bertinotti en
faveur de l'égalité
quelle que soit l'orientation sexuelle
le gouvernement est totalement déterminé
à aller plus loin et à agir pour lutter
contre toutes les formes de violence et
de discrimination qui s'exerce sur les 1
du à raison de leur orientation vous
savez quand on pense qu'aujourd'hui un
homosexuel sur 4 a subi ces dix
dernières années des violences physiques
pour ce motif
on comprend que notre société reste
chargé d'une violence sourde façonné par
des stéréotypes en tout genre et bien
c'est contre ces stéréotypes contre ces
discriminations contre ces violences que
nous sommes aujourd'hui déterminés à
lutter totalement pour que dans tout les
monde dans tous les domaines de
l'éducation du sport du travail de la
santé nous fassions comme l'a dit l'une
d'entre vous sur un autre banc reculer
les archaïsmes
car c'est bien de cela qu'il s'agit le
premier ministre m'a confié la mission
d'animer le travail du gouvernement sur
ces questions
comptez sur moi pour mobiliser
l'ensemble des administrations
compétentes en lien avec mes collègues
bien entendu mais il s'agira de mettre
en action la détermination du
gouvernement
d'ores et déjà je peux vous dire que
nous sommes en train de relancer les
travaux aux nations unies pour que nous
fassions repartir cette dynamique en
faveur de la dépénalisation universelle
de l'homosexualité
nous travaillerons pour que en france
les victimes de ces violences n'hésite
plus à déposer plainte pour qu'elles
soient accompagnées pour qu'elles soient
mieux protégées qu'elles ne le sont
aujourd'hui
nous savons que la première cible de ses
victimes ce sont les plus jeunes dans
leur propre famille à l'école dans leur
quartier il faudra à cet égard mobiliser
des moyens à la fois pour travailler sur
le terrain pour faire acte de pédagogie
mais aussi de fermeté
c'est à tout cela que nous nous
engageons aujourd'hui sachez qu'une très
large concertation a été entamée pour
rédiger ce plan d'action très globale
d'ici la fin du mois d'octobre
les associations le monde de l'éducation
les élus locaux ils sont associés les
partenaires les parlementaires pardon le
seront également
je sais un particulièrement que dans
cette assemblée et sur tous les bancs
des propositions ambitieuses ont été
faites sur ces sujets je compte sur vous
pour nous accompagner dans cette belle
tâche merci et
madame elisabeth lamure pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur sapin ministre du travail de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
monsieur le ministre décidément les
volte face de vos annonces sont à la
mesure du jugement très sévère que les
français vous adresse ces derniers jours
concernant votre gouvernance
si le contexte économique et social
n'était pas aussi inquiétant pour notre
pays voire catastrophiques pour nombre
de françaises et de français nous
portons plus à la tristesse coup sourire
je reprendrai volontiers ses mots d'un
homme d'esprit
pierre dac ce n'est pas un tournant le
dos aux choses qu'on leur fait face une
impression ressentie bien souvent au
cours de ces derniers mois
mais lorsque nous avons entendu le
président de la république dimanche
dernier à la télévision évoqué les
accords compétitivité emploi puis le
premier ministre mardi en renfort
reprenant le thème nous nous sommes dit
qu'il réouvrait le chantier de la
flexisécurité lancé par nicolas sarkozy
au début de l'année pour une fois
président et premier ministre nous
semble faire face le temps n'est pas si
loin où l'idée même de mettre de la
flexibilité semblait totalement hors
débat voire à bannir définitivement la
protection du droit du travail allait
quasiment disparaître pour les salariés
disent et on au parti socialiste
alors quel crédit accorder à de tels
revirements ou le jour d'après contredit
le jour d'avant
souvenons nous de quelle manière le
gouvernement socialiste a aggravé la
situation en alourdissant le coût du
travail dans le cadre de la loi de
finances votée en juillet taxant les
heures supplémentaires avec une vraie
perte de pouvoir d'achat pour les
salariés
taxant l'epargne salariale et en
augmentant les cotisations
monsieur le ministre en ce début de
rentrée vous semblez précipiter le
mouvement auprès des partenaires sociaux
dont on sait qu'une partie d'entre eux
n'est pas sur la ligne d'une franche
acceptation des termes de la
sécurisation de l'emploi tel qu'il se
pose alors pouvez vous nous dire quels
sont précisément vos objectifs et le
temps que vous souhaitez accordée aux
négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux
je vous remercie monsieur michel sapeurs
ministre du travail de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame le
sénateur
regardons justement les choses en face
sans leur tourner le dos les choses en
face c'est la situation de l'emploi
celles que vous nous avez laissé celle
que le gouvernement que vous souteniez
le président la république nous ont
laissé plus de 3 millions de chômeurs
parmi ces trois millions de chômeurs un
nombre de chômeurs de longue durée comme
jamais la france dans l'inconnu dans ces
trois millions de chômeurs cinq cent
mille jeunes qui sont sans formation et
sans emploi jamais la france n'avait
connu autant de jeunes ainsi
marginalisés loin de l'emploi
loin de la formation c'est le résultat
d'un échec mais c'est aussi une réalité
nous jugeons l'échec le vôtre mais nous
prenons la réalité parce que notre
responsabilité c'est aussi de donner des
réponses à cette réalité pour faire
bouger les choses
alors comment madame le sénateur
souhaitons nous nous attaquer mener
cette bataille du chômage
premièrement l'immédiat de l'immédiat
vous aviez utilisé les deux tiers des
emplois aidés au cours des trois
premiers mois de l'année
devinez pourquoi nous avons dû rétablir
pour la deuxième partie de l'année 80
mille emplois aidés de manière à faire
face à l'urgence des urgences
deuxième chose cette nuit à 3h30 du
matin ce matin à l'assemblée nationale
vous allez avoir bientôt à en débattre
nous avons adopté par dont le parlement
a adoptées l'assemblée nationale a
adopté un texte les emplois d'avenir qui
permettra justement de donner à cent
cinquante mille des cinq cent mille
jeunes dont je vous parlais
de nouveau une perspective c'est une
réponse concrète
troisièmement le contrat de génération
que nous avons voulu à la fois décidée
par le gouvernement dessiné par le
gouvernement mais aussi négocié par les
partenaires sociaux il s'en empare
ils vont donner des réponses très
rapidement sur ce sujet et dernier étage
très important faire bouger la
réglementation mais la faire bouger de
manière équilibrée
monsieur le sénateur à votre manière
flexibilité flexibilité comme si la
seule question qui était posée en droit
social et dans le fonctionnement des
entreprises
c'était de savoir comment on allait
faire plier l'échiné des travailleurs et
des salariés
ça n'est pas la question la question
c'est de faire en sorte qu'il y est à la
fois plus de sécurité pour les salariés
et plus de capacité d'adaptation pour
les entreprises et c'est ce dont tous
les partenaires sociaux du côté patronal
comme du côté syndical se sont emparés
ils s'engagent demain matin demain matin
cette négociation ils sont tous d'accord
pour aller vite parce qu'il ya une
urgence économique
une urgence sociale à laquelle il faut
donner des réponses équilibré dans deux
mois j'en suis persuadé un accord qui
pourrait être portée historique qui sera
équilibré permettra à notre économie et
notre société de s'en sortir mieux que
de l'état dans lequel vous l'avez
laissée merci madame dominique gillot
pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
jeunesse des sports de l'éducation
populaire et de vie associative les jeux
paralympiques ont été clôturés dimanche
dernier cette édition 2012 est une belle
réussite les organisateurs britanniques
animé d'une culture inclusive qui doit
faire exemple ont su mettre en valeur
des athlètes aux qualités sportives
exceptionnelles
de l'autre côté de la manche les places
des stades ont été prises d'assaut
l'intégralité des compétitions a été
retransmise sur une chaîne de télévision
grand public alors que chez nous il
fallait attendre une heure très tardive
pour avoir le résumé de la journée
alors je me réjouis que notre
gouvernement ait manifesté une
considération particulière et notamment
le président de la république françois
hollande qui est allé à londres avec
vous madame pour soutenir les athlètes
handisport c'est la première fois qu'un
président de la république française se
rend à des jeux paralympiques
la moisson de médailles de la france
était moins bonne qu'en 2008
cependant les sportifs français ont
réalisé des performances dont nous
pouvons être fiers
leurs exploits sont d'autant plus
remarquables que la plupart de ces
athlètes ne dispose pas des moyens que
les valides les mêmes moyens que les
valides pour financer leurs projets
personnels leurs déplacements et tout ce
qui est nécessaire à leur préparation
peu d'entre eux peuvent atteindre le
professionnalisme indispensable à
l'obtention des titres tant convoités
ainsi le retard de la france a été
douloureusement mis au jour par le
contraste entre la situation des
athlètes français et celle des
britanniques
les réponses de votre prédécesseur à mes
questions sur la politique de son
gouvernement relative au soutien des
athlètes handisport avait montré par
leur désinvolture et leur imprécision
une mésestime du mental des aptitudes et
des besoins de ces sportifs de haut
niveau tout autant que le manque
d'efforts concertés pour les accompagner
dans leur parcours
pourtant la loi de 2005 pour l'égalité
des droits et des chances la
participation et la citoyenneté des
personnes handicapées nous engage à
changer le regard de la société
mais aussi à garantir à nos concitoyens
handicapés l'accès à toutes les
activités pour les personnes handicapées
le sport est bien l'opportunité
d'affirmer leur place avec leur
singularité
il reste visiblement est scandaleusement
encore beaucoup à faire pour réduire les
inégalités d'accès aux pratiques
sportives dans notre pays
le handicap est une préoccupation forte
de l'action gouvernementale comme
l'affirment la circulaire du premier
ministre du 4 septembre dernier imposant
sa prise en compte dans tous les projets
de loi alors madame la ministre
pouvez vous nous faire un état de la
situation des athlètes handicapés que
vous avez trouvé à votre arrivée à votre
ministère quel bilan faites vous de la
dernière édition des jeux paralympiques
et comment comptez vous soutenir et
encourager la pratique sportive des
personnes handicapées amis amateurs et
de haut niveau dans la mixité sociale
que nous espérons de nos vues
si madame valérie fourneyron ministre
des sports de la jeunesse de l'éducation
populaire et de la vie associative c'est
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
madame la sénatrice dominique gillot
merci de me permettent de mettre en
valeur ces jeux paralympiques de londres
qui ont sans conteste été un tournant
dans la place du sport pour les
personnes en situation de handicap
cette 14e édition des jeux paralympiques
qui a permis de voir le retour de la
fédération française et de l'ensemble du
sport adapté dans un pays qui a vu
naître la place du sport pour les
personnes en situation de handicap
à l'issue du deuxième conflit mondial il
y avait à l'occasion de ces jeux
paralympiques 4200 athlètes 164 nation
et pour notre équipe nationale
163 sportives et sportifs qui ont
rapporté 45 médailles dont huit d'or
dans des compétitions avec des
performances toujours plus importante et
il y assure ce registre à nous tous de
les féliciter comme nous avons pu le
faire avec le président de la république
et avec ma collègue marié arlette
carlotti
ces jeux olympiques et ses jeux
paralympiques de londres vont
effectivement marqué un tournant dans
l'histoire du place du sport pour les
personnes en situation de handicap
d'abord par leur magnifique succès
populaire 2 millions 7,2 billets vendus
à 10 heures du matin il n'y avait pas
une place dans un stade de 80000
personnes aussi parce que il y a eu à
cette occasion une organisation et
c'était la première fois absolument
identique à celle des jeux olympiques en
matière de volontariat en matière de
cérémonie en matière d'organisation des
déplacements et en matière de l'ensemble
je veux dire de la discipline qui était
mise en valeur il ya vu une
médiatisation vous l'avais appelé
exceptionnel et l'exemple des
britanniques montrer combien c'est
direct l'ensemble des performances
étaient un objectif que nous devions
pouvoir atteindre la médiatisation a été
sur notre pays en progression il reste
encore je vais dire de grands de grandes
marches à franchir à franchir pour qu'
il y ait comme il ya eu à l'occasion de
ces jeux paralympiques
une véritable intégration dans le droit
commun comme c'est le cas dans la loi de
février 2005
cette intégration dans le droit commun
et non dans des lois spécifiques
notre mauvaise première mesure a été de
financer les primes de l'ensemble de nos
médaillés à la même hauteur que les
primes des valides et
sans oublier que pour la première fois
alors qu'il s'agit d'une tradition
républicaine des primes à l'occasion des
jeux celle ci n'avait pas été inscrite
dans le projet de loi de finances de
ce que votre assemblée avait noté avec
regret en l'appelant d'ailleurs bombe à
retardement dans ce cas d' égalité mais
aussi pouvoir améliorer l'accès au sport
pour toutes les personnes en situation
de handicap avec une première mission
qui a été confiée à l'inspection
générale avec mon collègue vincent
peillon et marié arlette carlotti pour
avoir un diagnostic précis de la place
du sport de l'école à l'université
deuxième élément indispensable qu'il y
ait dans l' enveloppe du cnds une
enveloppe qui soit consacré un souci
majeur pour les personnes en situation
de handicap qui est le matériel le
matériel coûte cher pour faire du sport
et donc il faut qu'il y a une
spécificité et une prise en compte
troisième élément nous sommes en train
de finaliser une charte avec le comité
paralympique et sportif français avec le
ministère et avec le comité olympique
pour qu'il y ait de plus en plus de
passerelles et au delà de passerelles
des changes avec des fédérations valide
et j'invite celles et ceux qui le
peuvent à aller voir le championnat du
monde d'escaladé en ce moment à paris où
il ya en même temps la compétition pour
les valides et pour les personnes en
situation de handicap ces échanges sont
nécessaires enfin ministre enfin il y à
la pérennisation des emplois qualifiés
qui sont je veux dire pour accompagner
ces fédérations du sport adapté et du
sport olympique
il y a à cette occasion la nécessité de
pérenniser ses emplois qualifiés
je termine en disant que le président de
la république recevra lundi l'ensemble
de nos sportifs médaillés aux jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de londres
merci nous en avons fini avec les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
mais chers collègues je vais vous donner
lecture de l'ordre du jour du lundi 24
septembre 2012 à 14h30 et le soir projet
de loi portant création d emplois
d'avenir la séance est levée
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre en direct
sur notre antenne la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
on se retrouve tout de suite au même
endroit avec nos invités les ministres
les parlementaires concernés à tous les
temps